james r
wants to know what are his thoughts on
mind uploading digital consciousness and
such ideas
i think
those ideas
are
again they're
we're in this world
where people get excited about ideas
like that that haven't been fully
thought out
all right so similar to the free will
question being simplistic yes it's too
simple so so let me let me at least say
why so that people don't get mad um
so uploading your brain into a computer
right and then you're supposed to be a
conscious dude who like walks around and
does all sorts of cool stuff inside the
computer all right well that implies
that
thinking is what
makes you conscious because that's like
the computer would be doing simple
manipulation we already know that's not
true and in fact anyone who's
been done any successful meditation at
all for even like a minute
knows that thinking is not what makes
you conscious thinking is a thing that
you're conscious of right
so
you have to be talking about
replicating something besides the
thinking part that's actually the vast
majority of your experience okay so
that's part a part b
um
if that is suddenly conscious why why
are other things that computers are
already doing not conscious they're
pretty complicated
right um and if something a computer
does can be conscious
um
why
like what's a computation do you even
know
like i actually don't understand to this
day what a computation is right i still
am trying to understand that and so
there's this rhetorical magic doing a
lot of work where like oh if a computer
is computing things and simulating you
then that simulation will be conscious
and it's like
if that's true
then it has some implications that you
haven't thought about that maybe other
things are conscious that you don't
think are conscious or that maybe
um
you know maybe maybe material has
aspects to it
if you have a materialist view maybe
material has aspects to it that you
haven't considered right and so
um it's i don't want to try to make the
full complete case here for that because
i haven't
prepared it or thought about it lately
but i i will say one of the speeches
that i gave a
private version of a year ago that i
want to give a full version of is um you
know one version of this is the
simulation argument is has been pretty
popular among people who
who talk about stuff and that is like oh
if you do the math it's actually likely
that we're living in a simulation right
now that's in a computer right and so
therefore of course you could simulate
yourself in another computer because you
already are in one and like
i think that argument is basically
meaningless and i can make a pretty good
case
as to
why it doesn't actually mean anything
but it probably takes an hour to make
that case
or more or two hours